When I was young, I thought my country was the best on the planet,...
...and I grew up singing a song called "Nothing to Envy."
And I was very proud.
In school, we spent a lot of time studying the history of Kim Il-Sung,...
...but we never learned much about the outside world,...
...except that America, South Korea, Japan are the enemies.
Although I often wondered about the outside world,...
...I thought I would spend my entire life in North Korea,...
...until everything suddenly changed.
When I was seven years old, I saw my first public execution,...
...but I thought my life in North Korea was normal.
My family was not poor, and myself, had never experienced hunger.
But one day, in 1995, my mom brought home a letter from a coworker's sister.
It read, "When you read this, all five family members will not exist in this world,...
...because we haven't eaten for the past two weeks."
"We are lying on the floor together, and our bodies are so weak we are ready to die."
I was so shocked.
This was the first time I heard that people in my country were suffering.
Soon after, when I was walking past a train station,...
...I saw something terrible that I can't erase from my memory.
A lifeless woman was lying on the ground,...
...while an emaciated child in her arms just stared helplessly at his mother's face.
But nobody helped them,...
...because they were so focused on taking care of themselves and their families.
A huge famine hit North Korea in the mid-1990s.
Ultimately, more than a million North Koreans died during the famine,...
...and many only survived by eating grass, bugs and tree bark.
Power outages also became more and more frequent,...
...so everything around me was completely dark at night...
...except for the sea of lights in China, just across the river from my home.
I always wondered why they had lights but we didn't.
This is a satellite picture showing North Korea at night compared to neighbors.
This is the Amrok River, which serves as a part of the border between North Korea and China.
As you can see, the river can be very narrow at certain points,...
...allowing North Koreans to secretly cross.
But many die.
Sometimes, I saw dead bodies floating down the river.
I can't reveal many details about how I left North Korea,...
...but I only can say that during the ugly years of the famine...
...I was sent to China to live with distant relatives.
But I only thought that I would be separated from my family for a short time.
I could have never imagined that it would take 14 years to live together.